le 17 février dernier euh le juge de
liberté de détention a signé à Résidence
Pierre Palmade dans le service
addictologie de l'hôpital Paul Brousse à
Villejuif d'accord ça veut dire quoi
donc ça veut dire qu'il n'y avait il ne
pouvait recevoir aucune visite il était
donc il y avait des
il était obligé de rester dans ce
service là et en plus de ça il portait
un bracelet électronique sauf que samedi
il a fait un AVC donc il a il a été
transféré à l'hôpital du Kremlin-Bicêtre
où il est sous surveillance médicale et
cette décision qui a été qui a été faite
le 17 février a été contesté par le
parquet et aujourd'hui ce lundi la cour
d'appel de Paris a ordonné la détention
provisoire de Pierre Palmade et
visiblement il a été écroué il serait
rattaché à la prison de Fred ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que pour l'instant on
ne sait pas s'il va aller vraiment
puisque selon mes infos son avocate
aurait déposé plusieurs recours
notamment à recours pour que pour qu'il
soit car serré dans l'unité de haute
surveillance de la Salpêtrière la
pitié-sal hier ou alors une demande de
d'assignation à domicile avec une remise
en liberté et avec également des
tensions de du bracelet électronique
donc ça c'est les recours qu'apportaient
sur l'avocat et c'est en cours donc il
se peut que voilà et finalement il
n'aille pas forcément en prison tout de
suite en tout cas à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui il est il va pas il est
prêt il a faim
il y a des gens aussi
c'est un accident
cérébral
c'est c'est une sorte de non afflux du
sang vers le cerveau donc une non
alimentation
très vite en charge alors entre une
demi-heure et 4 heures sinon c'est fini
et ça peut provoquer des troubles ce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est la gravité de
l'AVC et si c'est le premier AVC ou le
deuxième AVC d'une série parce que
parfois c'est en série alors ce qui a
surpris c'est que un AVC peut être lié à
la prise de cocaïne comme là il est en
sevrage on se demande si on a ré eu un
avant ou pas et ça peut faire perdre la
parole entraîner des problèmes de
mobilité selon la gravité voilà alors
visiblement enfin il y a aussi des gens
qui disent que ce serait pas vraiment un
AVC mais plutôt ce qu'on appelle un
accident ischémique transitoire qui est
dû notamment la prise de cocaïne et de
produits de substitution qui est
beaucoup moins grave qu'un AVC qui est
vraiment quelque chose de transitoire
donc voilà est-ce que aussi ça va
l'aider
de Paris ce matin non il y était pas il
était pas non plus vendredi quand le
parquet a fait a fait ses réquisitions
et là actuellement il est toujours au
Kremlin-Bicêtre ou surveillance médicale
et les médecins ont demandé à ce qu'on
lui enlève le bracelet électronique de
confort c'est prononcé
sur sur l'affaire lui ou est-ce qu'on a
eu que le communiqué de sa sœur non il a
fait alors moi mes infos je vais
peut-être choquer beaucoup de gens mais
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il était pas
extrêmement repentant par rapport à ce
qui s'était passé selon mes dernières
infos je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire ce que
moi on m'a dit parce que voilà j'étais
pas là au moment où il a dit mais en
tout cas visiblement
il est pas extrêmement repentant par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé la fin en
tout cas par rapport à l'accident et au
fait que une femme est perdue est perdue
son bébé ce qui contredit alors la
lettre de la sœur alors ce qui contredit
la lettre de la sœur en fait la soeur
doit selon mes informations lui aurait
demandé lui à lui aurait demandé en fait
d'écrire cette lettre lui-même et il
aurait refusé et c'est elle qui a pris
l'initiative de écrire cette lettre
alors
oui mais en revanche ça a été la stupeur
quand le Pierre Palmade a été mis au
courant par ses avocats de la décision
on la décrit comme complètement perdu
choqué etc on le sera à moi tout à fait
normal je je ne défends pas du tout mais
visiblement même de son côté on ne
s'attendait pas du tout à ce qui est
quand même un coup de perdre alors
justement parce que cette décision c'est
vrai que c'est un coup de théâtre genre
je fais une ancien magistrat comment se
fait-il que la Cour d'appel soit revenue
sur la première décision puisque il
devait pas leur prison à la base
le parquet avait fait appel de cette
décision qui était une bonne décision
faut moi je pense que le fait de l'avoir
assigné à résidence avec un bracelet
électronique et puis des soins pour son
addiction c'était la meilleure des
décisions qu'on pouvait prendre ce que
vous nous aviez dit à la fois
pour n'importe je pense que beaucoup
beaucoup de juristes que moi je dirais
ont été surpris de l'affirmation de
cette décision par la chambre
d'instruction qui est la jurdiction du
second degré la josillon supérieur il y
avait trois au magistrats qui ont statué
après avoir délibéré ils n'ont pas eu la
même lecture finalement de la nécessité
ou pas d'une détention provisoire ils
ont estimé c'est leur argumentaire d'une
part qu'il y avait des risques de
réitération ou de récidive moi je vois
pas comment il aurait pu effectivement
sortir avec un bracelet reprendre un
volant scoquer une raison me paraît
assez assez peu probable et la deuxième
argument
la deuxième motivation ça a été de dire
que il fallait éviter des concertations
frauduleuses avec les autres témoins
passagers il fallait donc préserver les
investigations de l'enquête là aussi on
peut quand même s'étonner dans la mesure
où tout le monde a été entendu ou les
constatations ont été faites ou les
perquisitions ont lieu donc on voit pas
très bien comment il aurait pu
dissimuler des preuves ou quoi que ce
soit voilà donc on a une décision qui
est surprenante qui est ce que j'ai
enfin je veux dire il y a légitimité
j'en mets pas en cause mais elle est
quand même surprenante est-ce que est-ce
que les deux affaires qui sont sortis la
dernièrement ont pu un petit peu
influencer la décision de la Cour
d'appel ou pas du tout alors c'est là
qu'effectivement on peut se poser la
question comment les magistrats ont-ils
réfléchi à tout cela est-ce qu'ils sont
contentés uniquement si je puis dire de
cet accident dramatique ou bien est-ce
que évidemment ils écoutent comme tous
les informations ils savent qu'il y a
deux autres enquêtes
dont une de pédopornographique quand
même pour l'instant il n'a pas été
entendu ni mis en cause et puis je pense
aussi que les magistrats sont pas
insensibles à l'émotion énorme qui a eu
lieu dans le pays ça s'appelle le
trouble à l'ordre public et même si le
trouble et leur public n'est plus un
critère aujourd'hui de mise en détention
en matière délictuelle ça leur reste en
matière criminelle sans doute que dans
leur fort intérieur tous ces affaires et
cette émotion dans le pays a peut-être
pesé dans cette décision mais je
rappelle si elle je rappelle que la
détention provisoire ça n'est pas une
sanction c'est un moyen de préserver les
investigations d'empêcher la fuite d'un
auteur c'est pas une présomption ça ne
préjuge en rien de ce que le tribunal
dira plus tard contenu de la gravité des
faits alors justement est-ce que c'est
la question elle est simple savoir elle
était spectateurs pierre Palma dit
valent en prison ou pas alors pas dans
l'immédiat parce que son état a été jugé
incompatible il a déjà été examiné avec
une détention mais dans l'avenir très
probablement souvenons-nous quand même
de l'exemple de Madame Balkany qui à peu
près de manière similaire elle n'a pas
été jugée accessible à la détention
alors qu'elles sont état de santé était
préoccupant mais je voudrais juste
revenir sur ce que disait Georges et je
suis totalement d'accord
ils n'ont pas jugé que sur l'affaire de
l'accident ils ont jugé sur l'ensemble
voilà il ne devrait pas juridiquement
mais on va pas se le cacher il a été
est-ce qu'on peut mettre un homme qui a
fait un AVC deux jours plus tôt et qu'on
peut le mettre en prison oui parce que
maintenant notamment à Fred il y a un
hôpital dans le périmètre de la prison à
côté tout à fait équipé donc oui s'il
avait Séné n'est pas grave grave ici
normalement il peut être soigné dans un
cadre pénitentiaire l'administration
pénitentiaire étant équipée et
scrupuleuse en la matière c'est possible
quel est le dernier mot c'est le juge ou
le médecin
le juge a toujours le dernier mot
d'accord mais lorsque le médecin vient
vous dire son transport aujourd'hui
présente un risque pour sa santé est
évident que le juge va pas prendre ce
risque là je suis une raison mais je
vous permettais je crois que c'est
Raymond qui est là elle est vraiment il
est là il est là je vous ai entendu tout
à l'heure en entrant avant d'entrer et
dire qu'il y a une justice pour les
puissants une justice pour les
misérables si on reprend la formule de
Jean de La Fontaine je vous assure que
non maman et je peux
faire la liste de tous les les ministres
des présidents de la République qui ont
comparé devant juridiction de ceux qui
ont été incarcérés des grands patrons
etc dire presque à la limite à la limite
il y a un excès
je vais prendre l'exemple
je vais prendre même l'exemple de Pierre
Palmade je vous pose la question genre
si ça avait pas été pire palmal est-ce
que il aurait été mis en détention ou
pas
mais je me pose la question on se pose
la question franchement
était de ne pas le mettre parce que
Pierre Palmade et que l'émotion a été
très forte une histoire de
pédopornographie
les deux les deux personnes qui ont été
mises en garde à vue il y en a un sur
les deux celui qui était auditionné à
Bordeaux qui a été mis en examen et qui
a porté des vidéos où on voit
effectivement Pierre Palmade visionné
des actes sexuels fait par des mineurs
avec quelqu'un et puis il a expliqué il
a expliqué que ce que Pierre Palmas se
serait vanter à plusieurs reprises
d'avoir deux enfants
âgés de 7 à 9 ans pour avoir des des
pour assouvir sa perversion sexuelle
c'est ce qui a été dit c'est quand même
des actes très très grave et que moi
personnellement je trouve pas ça
choquant que Pierre Palmade soit en
prison encore faut-il qu'il y aille
alors justement nous sommes avec Ingrid
ingrido email première surveillante à la
prison de la Santé pourquoi ils ont
choisi la prison de Fresnes d'ailleurs
justement oui il y a un hôpital dans le
périmètre de la prison qui permet de
suivre des cas extrêmement compliqués
même au niveau sanitaire alors
et c'est en Île-de-France il fallait que
ce soit en Île-de-France compte alors
donc il devrait arriver donc à la prison
de Fresnes comment ça se passe pour un
détenu VIP Ingrid on dit entre
guillemets oui entre guillemets parce
que il y a pas de de prise en charge
spécifique non ça reste un détenu tout à
fait normal pour nous c'est pas parce
qu'il est connu en fait donc il sera
pris en charge quand il va arriver il
verra la direction le service médical il
verra tous les services qui sont dans la
prison et à l'issue on va l'affecter sur
un bâtiment pour un détenu tout à fait
classique pour lui étant malade
apparemment ce que c'est ce qui se dit
effectivement on peut le mettre à
l'EPSNF à Fresnes effectivement comme
comme l'a dit et quand tu seras plus
malade ils vont faire quoi
on peut le transférer dans une cellule
normale quoi avec quelqu'un il sera seul
ou il sera avec voilà
après ça ça dépend de la configuration
de l'établissement mais
il peut être seul comme il peut être
avec quelqu'un d'autre
il y a quand même un quartier un peu
plus réservé disons aux personnalités
non pas pour qu'ils aient un statut
meilleur oui voilà
et il ne rentre pas en contact avec le
reste de la détention les autres détenus
ne serait-ce que pour les protéger
eux-mêmes on dit le quartier VIP ça veut
pas dire des mesures de faveur ça veut
dire qu'il faut les isoler quelque part
parce que ça peut exciter certains
autres
moi je ne suis pas d'accord
jamais dû se retrouver en contact avec
un mot détenu donc il faut la migration
potentielle elle a en charge la sécurité
et quand vous avez des personnalités
très connues ça peut mais quand il
rentre dans la cellule vous êtes
d'accord qu'il a plus le téléphone
accessible la télé accessible
on a regardé ce que vous dites
non non non non non donc ça sert à quoi
de mettre des quartiers donc tout ce
qu'on nous a raconté dans les médias
dans la presse dans les journaux sur les
cellules de quartier VIP à l'époque
Monsieur balkanietta est tant d'autres
politiques étaient Bernard Tapie et
compagnie toutes les cellules qu'on a vu
avec les grandes télé le grand confort
les grands moelleux confortable à un
seul tout ça c'est du mensonge j'ai
inventé je suis fou alors je sais pas
alors peut-être que moi j'ai envie de
mentir ça fait 16 ans que je suis dans
la profession et moi je l'ai jamais vu
je n'ai jamais vu non
ça n'existe pas par contre ceux qui a
toujours été fait c'est qu'effectivement
pour les protéger des autres détenus
parce que ça peut arriver le raquette
existe en prison on peut pas mettre en
surveillant derrière derrière chaque
détenu donc résultat on est obligé de
les protéger puisque c'est notre
première mission dans le même état le
même état voilà donc après si les
cellules de dans le dans ce quartier et
un peu plus propre c'est parce que il y
a peut-être moins de passage que c'est
moins dégradé mais c'est pas du fait de
l'administration vous avez déjà eu des
personnalités à la santé oui Balkany on
va pareil mais pareil pareil
ça dépend il y a certains des fois on
est obligé de les doubler comme par
exemple le cas de de Pierre Palmade
effectivement il paraîtrait qu'il a des
envies suicidaires d'après ceux que j'ai
entendu bah lui par exemple on pourra le
doubler pour être sûr qu'il se passe
rien dans la nuit parce que bah oui on
va essayer de le mettre avec quelqu'un
mais ça s'apprête c'est la direction qui
va décider mais dans l'idéal il y a
certains profils on peut pas les laisser
tout seul même si c'est des personnes
qu'il faut protéger justement à vouloir
les protéger on est obligé de les mettre
avec quelqu'un moi je voudrais dire à
quel point leur travail est extrêmement
difficile compte tenu des manques de
moyens et de place dans les prisons vous
savez qu'il y a 70 000 détenus
aujourd'hui en France pour 60 000 places
c'est ça et que vous avez des
populations à isoler on pense par
exemple aux auteurs d'infraction
sexuelles vous pouvez pas les laisser
avec le reste de la population pénale je
pense aussi maintenant alors c'est autre
chose aux individus pour terrorisme ou
radicaliser il faut aussi les isoler
pour éviter le prosélytisme donc vous
devez gérer une pénurie avec des
situations très compliquées c'est ça qui
tiennent sa réponse moi il y a plein de
choses qui me gênent mais après moi
j'invente moi ça me gêne par exemple les
gens qui font des problèmes avec ça
les gens les gens font des problèmes
avec la pédophilie etc etc moi je ne
veux pas qu'ils aient je ne veux pas
qu'il soit isolés je ne veux pas qu'on
leur fasse des traitements de faveur je
ne veulent pas qu'ils aient jouent à la
pétanque à 100 bonnes à 100 bornes de
Paris
préparer des petits plats c'est ma
vision des choses alors peut-être que
j'ai inventé tout ça peut-être que ça
n'existe pas mais bon voilà moi pour moi
c'est traitement de faveur pour tout le
monde alors pour tout le monde
vous savez pourquoi ils sont protégés en
fait pourquoi
ma question c'est pourquoi tu as
internet
mais en fait nous notre première mission
c'est de les garder en vie donc alors si
on les met et que et que les autres
détenus savent qui sont là pour
pédophilie vous imaginez le carnage donc
c'est qui qui prend après c'est
l'administration pénitentiaire donc au
moment au moment où on prend la décision
de les écarter du reste de la population
pénale c'est pour leur sécurité et pour
éviter des problèmes c'est tout donc ils
ont pas de traitement faveur particulier
qui rentre en prison café une bêtise
avec son permis de conduire qui a fait
une bêtise avec du cannabis une petite
bêtise de rien du tout vous les osez pas
lui pourtant il pète fragile dans sa
tête et il va y avoir dans les douches
avec
il peut demander à être isolé
vraiment un système où on me fait croire
que il y a des gens fragiles parce
qu'ils sont VIP politique etc Cela et
les pédophiles et cetera cela attention
ouh là là faut pas qu'ils aient avec les
autres et le pauvre monsieur qui a roulé
sans permis et qui a fait car un
crochage de rien du tout lui on s'occupe
pas de savoir s'il va bien on le fou
dans la bouche avec moi
être protégé
non mais tu feras un débat demain est-ce
que vous avez la pression lorsque vous
avez ce type de détenus
non on n'a pas de pression à avoir nous
on est juste là pour faire respecter les
décisions des juges donc on travaille
normalement on nous dit il faut mettre
le détenu là qui soit Pierre Paul
Jacques ça ne change rien dans la façon
qu'on va gérer sauf s'il y a des
consignes particulières oui Nicolas moi
j'ai une question à vous poser c'est le
calendrier parce que vraisemblablement
il va y avoir plusieurs affaires donc là
concrètement dans les semaines et dans
les mois qui viennent qu'est-ce qui va
se passer exactement
il y a d'abord l'affaire d'accident sous
l'emprise de produits stupéfiants donc
un jeu instruction qui travaille ça va
prendre du temps va falloir des
expertises les véhicules savoir parce
qu'on sait toujours pas aujourd'hui
Pourquoi il y a eu cette
chance qu'il va faire pareil
combien de temps pour quatre mois
renouvelable deux fois au maximum c'est
à dire un an au maximum mais le jeu
instruction peut estimer qu'il la plus
besoin de le maintenir en détention
provisoire et le relâcher avant cette
possible bien sûr que c'est possible
parce que c'est une nouvelle requête en
fait une nouvelle requête devant le juge
d'instruction le juge de la liberté la
détention pour demander sa mise en
liberté ou en aménagement dans un
hôpital prison et l'enquête peut être
longue alors l'enquête elle va durer
l'enquête elle va durer au moins un an
au moins un an plus les délais
d'audiencement c'est un procès qui
arrivera peut-être dans deux ans de
bonnes juridiction correctionnelle et
parallèlement vous avez des autres deux
autres enquêtes qui vont se poursuivre
avec saisine déjà d'un autre jeu qui
ressortent qui ressortent dans six mois
dans 8 mois mais bien sûr
ce qui veut pas dire que il ne
retournerait pas éventuellement en
prison puisque comme vous le savez il en
cours quand même 10 ans d'emprisonnement
donc un tribunal correctionnel pourrait
le condamner lourdement
comment vous les victimes alors les
victimes ça c'est pas la femme enceinte
est très très dépressive le père lui a
subi donc six opérations ou cette
opérations il est plus il est plus dans
le coma mais il va toujours très très
mal il est complètement fracturé
fracturé de partout
on sait enfin pour l'instant on peut
même pas dire que son état est vraiment
c'est vraiment amélioré parce qu'il est
vraiment broyé à tous les niveaux quant
au quant aux petits garçons de de six
ans qui avait donc la mâchoire cassée il
est alimenté avec une paille visiblement
il a de très grosses difficultés à
parler et pourra certainement pas se
ravitailler enfin manger normalement
à l'avenir donc voilà leur état est
vraiment très critique encore
aujourd'hui et le père et le fils sont
encore à l'hôpital alors que la maman
enfin celle qui aurait dû être devenir
maman est sorti de l'hôpital la semaine
dernière
leur reconstruction s'y reconstruction
il y a si elle est possible du rat des
années tant sur le plan psychologique
que physique c'est leur avocat qui s'est
exprimé être mouradmatique là dessus et
les trois effectivement vont très très
mal très très mal alors peut-être que ça
aussi ça a pesé sur le jugement voilà
mais les trois victimes ne sont dans un
état extrêmement compliqué juste petite
question docteur d'aujourd'hui il est à
l'hôpital oui est-ce que ça compte comme
la détention oui alors oui ça compte
comme la détention il a un numéro
d'écrou d'ailleurs ça ça a démarré ça
compte comme 14h30
donc là il est en détention il y a deux
policiers devant sa chambre sortir en
dehors du corps médical donc ça fait
partie des 4 mois ça commence sa famille
ne peut pas rentrer non faut avoir une
autorisation donc là voilà donc là il
est il est le régime son placement des
tensions provisoire pourra pas accéder à
non oui 4 mois et comme disait genre
multiplier les demandes de mise en
liberté ça c'est sûr très rapidement ces
endroits des deux des deux personnes qui
étaient avec lui dans la voiture pour le
moment il y a pas de nouveau elles sont
à ce niveau-là de la faire elles sont
placées sur les statut de témoin assisté
ne sont pas mis en examen ça va demander
de multiples expertises et c'est vrai
que ça va être long parce que déjà pour
la voiture il va y avoir expert contre
expert savoir ce qui s'est passé et il y
aura également de nouvelles expertises
concernant le foetus puisque la première
autopsie n'a pas permis de déterminer
s'il est né vivant ou pas et c'est
extrêmement important parce que s'il est
né vivant ça pourrait vouloir dire que
Pierre Palmade restreignait en examen
pour homicide moi j'aimerais bien que
c'est durisprudence évolue oui que le
législateur interne pour dire qu'il peut
y avoir un homicide involontaire sur un
circuit bien sûr on lui a fait perdre
une chance de vie parce que cet enfant
allait naître et je regrette
véritablement que on ne modifie pas la
jurisprudence tonnes dire Ingrid si vous
permettez
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure oui depuis
cet accident il y a 15 jours
statistiquement il y a déjà eu au moins
20 morts d'accidents de la route sous
l'emprise de produits stupéfiants
j'avais raison on parle beaucoup de
cette affaire parce que c'est dramatique
parce que c'est pire Balmain mais il y a
plus de 700 morts sur les routes chaque
année suite à des conduites sous emprise
de stupéfiants et on en parle pas et
cette malheureuse à faire permet
effectivement de montrer ce qu'est ce
fléau non juste il y a des questions qui
arrivent est-ce que Pierre Palmade
aurait accès à la télé à Internet mais
sa chambre d'hôpital
normalement non il a pas accès les
conscients
et George est-ce que ça vous choque la
pression médiatique et sans doute
compter dans la décision bien est-ce que
c'est normal ça fait partie de ces
mineurs c'est inconscient mais on a
tellement parlé que même les juges un
moment
un juge doit faire abstraction de toutes
les pressions d'où elles viennent y
compris médiatique quand vous êtes dans
un cabinet d'instruction ou quand vous
êtes en délibéré dans une cour d'assises
vous devez regarder l'affaire que
l'affaire vous ne devez pas être soumis
à toute forme de pression quelle qu'elle
soit mais une fois qu'on a dit ça la
justice elle est rendue par des hommes
et des femmes et donc ils écoutent ce
qui se passe et heureusement d'ailleurs
que les magistrats sont pas des robots à
l'abri de tout ils doivent tenir compte
aussi de tout un contexte sont pas des
pressions ils intègrent dans leur
décision
l'importance de l'événement et la
répercussion qu'il a eu ça n'est pas
scandaleux au fond qu'un juge écoute la
société je rappelle que la justice elle
est rendue au nom de du peuple donc en
autre nom